Nicholas Cage did a whole lot more than
just pop some fake Chompers in his mouth
to play Dracula and Renfield he
permanently altered his teeth so he
could play The Prince of Darkness cage
is famous for throwing himself entirely
into the roles he plays with a penchant
for absolute commitment to his
characters no matter how outlandish they
may be as Dracula and Renfield the famed
Mega acting practitioner might have been
forgiven for taking it easy for once
given that the movie is a breezy horror
comedy that recasts the immortal vampire
as the ultimate codependent boss yet in
a variety interview to promote the film
makeup artist Christian Tinsley revealed
that cage took an almost unbelievably
drastic step towards bringing his
character closer to the very image of
undeath let's see as with most on-screen
portrayals of Count Dracula Cage's
version strongly emphasizes the fangs
most actors would have probably been
content to let modern day CGI reshape
their teeth but Tinsley says cage took a
different approach using 3D printed
Dentures for maximum flexibility and
adjustment cage was evidently not
interested in his speech being impeded
by the dentures in any way since
explained we shaved Nick's teeth down
and the Dentures were fitted so as not
to impede on Nick's speech and allow
full Freedom Nick wanted to emote and
enunciate properly so it was important
the veneers were thin dental work was
actually just one step in an arduous
constantly evolving process of getting
cage into costume and ready to film
Dracula's appearance changes four times
over the course of the film and the
makeup Department engineered four
separate processes for the character's
different looks Tinsley says the first
look took roughly three and a half hours
to apply to cage each time he added it
was a full head of Prosthetics Dentures
full body torso arms hands and nails
those take time while the subsequent
designs for Dracula at later stages in
the movie didn't take as much time to
apply there was still a lot of effort
involved in seeing through Tinsley's
Creative Vision for the character's look
the makeup artist explained there's a
blue hue about him it's very iridescent
if you see it in person he almost looks
like a metallic robot I added a lot of
teal iridescence to the makeup in person
he would Shimmer and shine and on camera
it allows for a healthy glow to the skin
so he doesn't look like a cadaver of
course when filming wrapped cage was
able to remove most of the makeup and
Prosthetics and go back to his good old
pre-dracula appearance there's no one
shaving those teeth though cage having
his teeth shaved down to better
accommodate his Dracula Fangs for
Renfield is destined to become a piece
of vampire movie lore like Bella Lugosi
being buried in his Dracula Cape or Gary
Oldman sleeping in a coffin every night
but as drastic can act as it may seem
it's actually not the first time cage
has gone to such lengths for a part in a
1985 interview promoting the film birdie
cage explained how he had two teeth
removed without any anesthetic to
portray the disfigured War veteran
character he played it was just the
phase I was going through at the time to
explore that kind of approach to acting
which was to physically make demands on
myself it's remarkable he's gone down
the route of method acting through
dental work at least twice in his career
as cage has demonstrated decades later
his Ultra commitment to getting into
character was anything but a phase